Transcriber: İlker ÖZBAŞ
Gözden geçirme: Yiğit Yıldırım
Ben bir sanatçıyım.
Bir ressamım ve dünyayı çok renkli
algılıyor olmamızı çok büyük bir nimet
olarak görüyorum.
Sadece renklerin değil, biçimlerin,
coğrafyaların, insanların, ırkların
çeşitliliği çok büyük bir nimet, çünkü
ancak böylece farklı
ve kapsayıcı düşünme biçimlerine,
yaratıcı bakış açılarına
sahip olabiliyoruz.
Yalnız bilişsel bilimciler, tabii bu
bakış açılarına sahip olmak, bu
çeşitlilik,
bilinçli bir farkındalıkla
gelişen bu çeşitlilikten
faydalanabilmek,
bilinçli bir farkındalıkla
gelişen bir durum.
Bilişsel bilimciler, beyni kendi
işleyişine bıraktığımızda tek düze
belirli kalıplarda hareket
ettiğini söylüyorlar.
Etrafta bir sürü şey olsa da onlar bu tip
beyinler sadece aynı şeyleri görüp aynı
şeyleri duyabiliyorlar etrafta.
Ve maalesef böyle kalıplaşmış beyinlerle
gerçeğe ulaşmak çok fazla mümkün değil.
Çünkü yüzyıllar boyunca bilim insanları
ve filozoflar
gerçeğin çok değişken ve
çok yönlü karmaşık bir yapısı olduğunu
söylüyorlar ve
gerçeğe ulaşabilmek
ancak kuşkucu insanlara
mahsus bir özellik.
Ve tarihin bildiğimiz ilk kuşkucularından
bir tanesi.
Sokrates.
Sokrates, kelimelerin karmaşasının yerine
diyaloğu koyan ilk filozof.
Diyalog sanıyorum ilk defa Sicilya’da bir
mim ya da pandomim sanatı olarak ortaya
çıktı .
Sokrates ilk defa keşfetmedi ama
Sokrates tek başına zeki
olunamayacağını, bunun için bir
başkasının teşvik edici etkisinin şart
olduğunu söyleyen ilk düşünür.
Sokrates'in annesi ebe idi ve o da
düşüncelerin doğması için de ebelere
ihtiyaç olduğunu, ebelere gereksinim
duyulduğunu düşünüyor ve kendisini bu
anlamda annesinin izinde görüyordu.
Ve onun parlak düşüncesine göre
iki kişi
ancak bir araya geldiğinde gerçeği kendi
gerçeğini keşfedebilirdi ve tek başına
yapamayacağı bir şeyi yapabilir
duruma gelirdi.
Ama biraz önce söylediğim gibi
yenilikçi düşüncelerden
ve insanlardan yozlaşmış
beyinler hortlakmışcasına korktuklarından
Sokratese de baldıran zehri içirdiler.
Jacques-Louis David ünlü Fransız
ressam, Sokrates’in ölümü
sahnesini resmediyor burada.
Sokrates, kendisine sunulan diğer
teklifleri de reddederek, sorgulamayacağı
bir hayatın yaşamaya değer
olmadığını söylüyor ve zor olan, dostlarım
ölümden kurtulmak değil, kötülük
yapmaktan kaçmaktır.
Çünkü o ölümden hızlı koşar ve beni mahkûm
edenlere söyleyeceğim son söz
budur diyerek son dersinde veriyor
ve öğrencisinin ona sunduğu
baldıran zehrini içiyor.
Bu yozlaşmış beyinlere ikinci
başkaldırının Rönesans döneminde
kadınlardan geldiğini biliyoruz
tarihten.
Bunlar da insani başarının,
askeri güçten, bir hamle edinmekten ya da
asil kan sahibi olmaktan öte
gitmediği dönemlerde güç gösterisi ya da
meydan okumanın dışında diyalogların
gelişmediği yıllarda ilk başkaldırı
sarayın kadınlarından geliyor ve onlar,
her milletten,
yaşlı genç, zengin fakir
ayrımı yapmaksızın, kadın erkek ayrımı
yapmaksızın en başta, söyleyecek değerli
bir düşüncesi olan ve bunu zarafetle dile
getiren herkesi bir araya topladıkları
salonlar kuruyorlar.
Madam Duhambre’nin  öncülük ettiği
bu salonlar İtalya’dan Avrupa’ya ve oradan
ötesine yaygınlaşıyor.
Ve Montaigne’nin doğanın çeşitliliği ve
uyumsuzluğu düşüncesine sahip çıkıp ilk
defa kadınlar ve erkekler birbirlerinin
farklılıklarını
dinleme, kabul etme ve
bundan bir şeyler öğrenme
çabası içine giriyorlar.
İlk defa birbirlerini sadece biçimsel
olarak değil, düşünsel olarak da
değerlendirme imkanı bulmuş oluyorlar.
Bir süre sonra kendi zekalarının
hayranlarına kapılarak bu salon
diyalogları da saray monolog larına
dönüyor belki ama biz tarihten Fransız
İhtilali'nin temellerini atan
düşüncelerin bu salonlardan
doğduğunu biliyoruz.
Bu da yine bir başka ressam,
ressamın
adını unuttum şu anda
heyecanımı...
Francois Dubois, Francois Dubois’in resmi
Madam Duhambre’nin salonunda.
Nitekim tarih bize yenilikçi düşüncelerin.
Barışçıl bakış açılarının ortaya
çıkabilmesi için kadın ve erkek ebelere
ihtiyaç olduğunu gösteriyor ve bu
işi kadınların çok daha iyi
yapabildiğini aslında.
Fakat kadınların birileri tarafından
belirlenmiş adam gibi sıfatlarıyla
nitelendirilen mükemmeliyet modelleriyle
ikna etme çabaları yerine, sözlerini
söylemeye, karanlık ormanlara cesaretle
dalıp o ormanlarda gerekli ipucunu
bulabileceklerini inanmaları şart.
Evet, hayat, kadınları erkeklere nazaran
çok daha fazla karanlık ormanlar içine
çekiyor ama bir o kadar da kendilerini
ve etraflarını aydınlatabilecekleri
sihirli ipuçları sunuyor.
Ben kendi hayatımdan böyle kısacık bir
dönemi paylaşmak istiyorum sizinle.
Sanatta yeterlik tezimi tamamlama
aşamasında çok yoğun çalıştığım bir
dönemde hamile olduğumu öğrendim.
Çocuk yapmak hem çok istediğim bir şeydi
hem de bir o kadar korktuğum bir şeydi.
Geçen gün bir filmde duyduğum ne
diyor insanlar kadınlardan,
babunlar gibi bir analık içgüdüsü
bekliyorlar ama öyle olmuyor diyor.
Evet, öyle olmuyor.
Çünkü akademik hayatın en önemli
aşamasında, sanat hayatının önemli bir
dönemecinde,
sanat camiasının baskısı
altında ve toplumsal bir hafızadan
edindiğimiz bilgilere nazaran iş hayatı
içerisinde biraz önce Pelin Hocamın da
söylediği kadın olma durumunun
zorluklarını çok iyi bilerek ve bu kadar
gönül verdiğimiz, emek verdiğimiz
işlerimiz ve birlikte acaba anne olmak,
iyi bir anne olmak, iyi bir akademisyen
olmak,
iyi bir ressam olmak mümkün olabilecek mi?
Kaygılarının o gün ne kadar yoğun
olduğunu ben şimdiki aklımla
çok daha iyi görebiliyorum.
Nitekim sanat camiası içerisinde de iyi
bir sanatçı olmak için öncelikle erkek
olmanız gerekir.
Her ikinci sırada bir ressam olabilmek
için ve sanatçı olabilmek için de çoluk
çocuklu, evli barklı bir
kadın olmamanız gerekir.
Bu ancak bir hobi ressamı
tanımlamasına dahil olabilir.
Nitekim bu böyle söylenmeyen ve bilinen
gerçeklerden değildir, insanın yüzüne
gümbür gümbür.
Bunu söylemekten de hiç çekinmezler.
Tabi ben o dönemde de zorluklarla başa
çıkarken bildiğim en iyi yolu resim yapma
yolunu takip ederken yaptığım resimler
oldukça beğeniliyor ve
ilgi görüyordu.
Hamileliğin ilk aylarında açtığım bir
sergide satılmış bir eserin ödemesini
almak üzere 1- 2 gün sonra koleksiyoner
ile buluştuğunda o resmin başında resme
övgüler yağdıran adamdan eser kalmamıştı .
Sanki onu aldatmış gibi inanılmaz bir
hayal kırıklığıyla ve çok büyük bir
sinirle siz hamileymişsiniz,
bunu bilsem resminizi satın almazdım dedi.
Ve o anda benim bastırmaya çalıştığım
bütün korkuları vücut bulmuş
hali oldu o kişi.
Nitekim resmi ona satmadım ve o resim
hala inandığım yolda yürümeye devam
ettiğimde sonunda sihirli ipuçlarını bulup
kendi istediğim gibi bir hayatı
tasarlayabileceğimiz göstergesi olarak
duvarımda asılı durur.
Bizler.
Ama, şunu söylemeden geçmeyelim.
Bir süre sonra, 7 ay sonra oğlumu
kucağıma aldığımda.
Tabii onu kucağımda asla bırakamıyorum.
İlk aylarda ve böyle içten içten, kimseye
itiraf etmesem de diyorum ki
adam haklıymış .
Yani ben biraz sert tepki gösterdim ona.
Hormonların etkisiyle herhalde bir şey
yapabilmem mümkün değil sanırım bu
bundan sonra.
Ama tabii hayatı düşündüğümüzde o
son derece kısa bir süre süreydi.
Ve ben o sürenin sonunda şunu fark ettim.
Başımıza öyküler yani hayat geldiğinde
zaman anlatısal bir form kazanıyordu
ve bu formun rengi ve kokusu vardı .
Benim için artık resim yapmak eskisine
göre daha kolay ve daha anlamlıydı .
Ve de şunu gördüm istediği kadar
iyi bir sanat eğitimi alsın.
Eğer bir kişi hayatın o derin ve anlamlı
akışını fark edemiyorsa, iyi bir sanatçı
olması mümkün değildi.
Tabii burada iyi bir sanatçı olmayla
bağlantılı olarak kadın olmak, anne olmak
gibi şeyleri, kıstasları
koymuyorum aslında.
Hayat bize her dönem toplumsal
gömlekler giydiriyor.
Biçilmiş gömlekleri üzerimize
giyiyoruz aslında.
Söylemeye çalıştığım, altını çizmeye
çalıştığım şey bir şu gömleklerin
çıkartıp, Sokrates den gittik yine
Sokrates’in o Delfi tapınağında yazan
kendini bil sözcüğüyle.
Kendimizi bilsek kendimizi bakmayı ve
aslında o gömlekler den bize neler uygun
onları teker teker almayı , hatta o
kalıpta değil, belki o roldeki o gömleği
kendi gördüğümüz rengarenk bir kazakla
giymeyi başarabilirsek, o zaman içinde
çok daha rahat olacağımız, çok daha
farklı ve yaratıcı çözümler
sunabileceğimiz
ve her şeyden önce
başarılı ve mutlu olmayı başaracağımız
bireyler olacağız.
Nitekim yine tabii ki söz etmeden bugün
burada ben de geçemeyeceğim.
Biz Mustafa Kemal Atatürk sayesinde
dünyanın birçok ülkesinden önce siyasi
haklarını , eğitim haklarını almış
çok şanslı Türk kadınlarıyız.
Atamızı her an minnetle, sevgiyle,
saygıyla anıyoruz.
Ve Atatürk'ün de yolumuzu açtığı ve
dünyada da bu hakları almış olan kadınlar.
Burada bugün konuşan sekiz kadın da
gösteriyor ki kadınlar büyük kitle
hareketlerini yönetebildiklerini
çok iyi yönetebildiklerini,
iş hayatının her alanında çok çok başarılı
olabildiklerini defalarca tüm
dünyaya gösterdiler.
Fakat dünyanın hiçbir yerinde, hiçbir
ülkesinde, en gelişmiş ülkeleri de dahil
cinsel cinsiyet ayrımcılığının,
biraz önce söylediğim gibi sıkıntılarına
maruz kalmamış bir kadın bile yoktur.
Bu işin masum tarafı maalesef gün geçmiyor
ki bu cinsel ayrımcılık yüzünden
çok şiddetli cinayetlerin
işlenmediğini duyalım.
Maalesef bu cinayet haberlerini
de sürekli duymaktayız.
Ve demek ki başka bir şey var.
Theodore Zeldin sosyal tarihçi.
Kadınlar ve erkekler arasındaki savaşı
dünyanın en eski ve en büyük savaşı
olarak nitelendiriyor ve diyor ki birkaç
metre toprak kazanmak ya da savunmak
adına kıran kırana verilen bir mücadele.
Fakat bu kara mücadelesi olurken
hava sahasında neler olduğu göz
ardı edildi diyor.
Hava sahası ne?
Her cins aslında tüm canlılar arasındaki
ilişkileri sarmalayan atmosfer, hayali
hudutlar ve değişmeyen mentaliteler.
Bu mentaliteler değişmedikçe
bu savaş bitmeyecek.
Çünkü evrensel bir kumanda
merkezi yok bu savaşın.
Bir evrensel ateşkes ilan edilerek
sonlanacak bir savaş değil.
Ancak kadın ve erkek ebelerin bir arada
doğuracağı empati ve diyalogla bitirilir.
Ve ben iddia ediyorum ki bu diyaloğun
kurulmasında en etkili araç sanattır.
Şimdi siz sanata çok ciddi bir misyon
yüklediğini düşünüyor olabilirsiniz.
Ama sanat tarih boyunca
insanlık tarihine,
insan başarısına belki de bilimden daha
fazla destek vermiştir.
Hiçbir ideoloji ya da din, sanatın gücünü
arkasına almadan yayılamamıştır.
İster fantezi, ister geçici bir heves
olsun, insan beyninin ürettiği
her şeye
saygınlık kazandırmakta muntazam
etkili bir araç olmuştur sanat.
Sanatçıların
o bildiğimiz son derece sıra
dışı hayatları , acılarla, hayal
kırıklıklarıyla dolu hayatları , onların
hep başka bir varoluşun peşinde
olduğunu gösterir.
Ve o varoluş amacı , bugün eskiye nazaran
çok daha değerli ve gelişmiş ülkelerde,
bu nedenle eğitim seviyesi yüksek
ülkelerde sanatsal bir hayata yönelim çok
ciddi bir önem kazanıyor.
Sanatçılar rollerini henüz
tamamlamadılar.
Bu yönelim önemli.
Yani böyle bir sanatsal arayış var.
Çünkü sanat bize bir talimat kitabı ya da
tarif kitabı başlangıç düzeyinde bir
beceriyi amaçlarken, sanat insanla
öngörülebilir bir amaçtan çok daha
fazlasını sunuyor.
Çünkü bir keşif yolculuğu ve bu keşfin
yönü her zaman değişebilir.
Perspektifi değişebilir ve bizim
yarınımızı bilmediğimiz, bugün de bir
beş sene sonrasını bile hayal
edemediğimiz bu çağda insanoğluna en
fazla insanoğluna ihtiyaç duyduğu
meziyet de budur aslında.
Sanatın kazandıracağı
bu meziyettir.
Sanat, insanın varoluş sürecinde
ortaya çıkan vizyonunu
tetikler ve bağımsız yaratıcılığı
destekler.
Hem bireyseldir hem de çok güçlü
bir iletişim aracıdır.
Hiç tanımadığınız beyinlerde duygu
ve düşünceler yaratabilirsiniz
Sanatla.
Sokrates gibi sorular sorup,
Madam Duhombre gibi
salonlar kurabilirsiniz.
Kadınlar ve erkekler birbirlerini tanıma
ve anlama olanağını ve birbirlerini ve
kendilerini sevme olanağını sanat
sayesinde bulabilirler.
Sanat bir cesaret eğitimidir.
Bilinmezliğe atılmış bir adımdır.
Umarım sizler de kadın ya da erkek
cesaretle kendi hayatınıza dair kendi
başınıza gelen öykülere adımınızı atıp
kanınızla gözyaşlarınızla,
kahkahalarınızle
kendi hayat resminizi yapmaya
cesaret edebilirseniz, bir ressam olarak
size bir ipucu vereyim.
Bütün renklere ihtiyaç duyacaksınız
ve bütün renkleri
kucaklayacak ve seveceksiniz.
Teşekkür ederim.